ja herzlich willkommen beim klicksum
Chaos Kochen heute machen wir Heringe
mit nutellasße Aprikosen und flüssigen
Gummibärchen na denn
[Musik]
Mahlzeit Premieren Gast ist Olli Bano
Kölner Rapper sein erfolgreichstes Album
kopfdisco ja das war auch das letzte
Album und so sieht's aus das nächste ist
in der Mache auf jeden Fall fast fertig
und ja großartig wir sind gespannt und
wir kochen heute bismaring mit wir
machen wir machen eine Variation wir
machen
nutellaasße wow das ist die einfache
Variation und Schokoladensoße weil da
kann ich dir das Rezept zeigen wie man
Schokoladen viele machen ja die
Schokoladensoße einfach Wasserbad und so
eine Fertigsoße aber es gibt viel
bessere Schokoladensoße man kauft eine
wirklich gute
Schokolade ja und wie man das dann macht
ohne dass sie anbrennt das zeige ich
gleich super ich bin sehr gespannt genau
aber das dann halt mit bism ob das was
wird wir werden
[Musik]
sehen ich habe das schon mal gesehen
Schokolade wird meistens Wasserbad
heißes Wasserbad irgendwie genau aber es
geht auch anders und zwar ein
[Musik]
haufmilch
was Unterschied zwischen orange und
Clementine keine Ahnung ich habe es
einfach gesehen dachte mal komm orange
immertine okay also bitte kommentieren
wer ma jetzt die Clementine vielle ist
ja auch eine Kreuzung
zwischen Mandarine und Orange wir haben
ja ein wunderbares Gerät nennt sich
Mikrowelle
restellen
und wenn du zu Hause kochst was kochst
du dann in in den meisten Fällen ist es
Pasta geht schnell kann ich ganz gut und
ja kann man immer essen finde ich so
welche Soßen unterschiedlich so mein
Geheimtipp was ich jetzt rausgefunden
habe ist Zimt in die Bolognese ist da
sind wir ja hier beim Thema quasi nicht
wirklich das ist wirklich das machen
Chefköche so das ist wirklich gut Zimt
in die Bolognese ist der Hammer nicht
nur an Weihnachten sondern generell das
ist wie irgendw beim bei schubacks
Burger Bren was an
guck mal da brennt was an aber es brennt
nicht an hab gerade ger aber brennt
nicht an aber vielleicht ist das nur so
so ein Science Fiction Topf deswegen
oder so das ist schon die milchchen die
[Musik]
MIL so ich habe mir noch eine Beilage
überlegt trockene Aprikosen so die legen
wir jetzt in Zitrone ein genau
hier boah zack wir haben eine Raumschiff
Enterprise Zitronenpresse genau mal
sagen
Zitronen Star Wars oder oder oder ganz
klar fr ganz
[Musik]
klar willst du mal rausnehmen
klar geht oder ja
geh wow jetzt ist es
optimal was möchest du jetzt machen ich
würde mal so ein Kreis versuchen zu
malen mit der Soße so wie
dieseöche
a die SAG im ich habe das oft so gesehen
gucken was mein kunstleistungskurs
gebracht hat
[Musik]
damals ja okay da geht noch
mehr ja und raus es gibt gerichtte ich
habe das jetzt gehört in Schweden da
gibt's Fisch der wird irgendwie draußen
im Wald eingelegt weil früher im Winter
hatten die Probleme irgendwie über die
Runden zu kommen dann haben sie Fisch
eingelegt das Problem ich weiß nicht ich
weiß nicht wie sie heißt aber diese
Speise muss so stinken dass sie in
Mietshäusern verboten istah weil das so
unglaublich ist also so viel zum Thema
Fisch aber ist es gibt auch auf auf DMAX
gibt's diese krasse Show wo dieser Typ
alle Länder besucht und die
Spezialitäten ist hast das gesehen ne
boah da gab's eine Folge mit Eskimo
sowas hast du nicht gesehen ich sag s
ein bis D ist ein scheiß deragegen
einmal J haben die nämlich so ein
Schlachtfest da wenn wird eine Robbe
geschlachtet in der Küche ja in der
Küche drei Generationen sind da Enkel
die Eltern und die Großeltern und
dann werden halt wird die zerlegt und
alle Essen die robereot ja und das sieht
einfach aus wie ein Horrorfilm weil alle
blutverschmiert sind und sich über diese
Robe hermachen das ist unglaublich so
sehe ich aus wenn ich spare Rips esse
richtig aber die sind wenigstens gut
durch richtig und es ist Ketchup
[Musik]
ja
was mit diesem Pumpernickel ach stimmt
die wollte ich als einfach dazu legen
die sind mir so ins Auge gesprungen ich
dachte Fisch und pumpernckel passt
[Musik]
muss ALR let's go let's go okay aber wir
müssen wirklich alles auf die Gabel rauf
kriegen al von allem würde ich sagen
würde ich sagen
bisschen ein bisschen
gummigoße ein bisschen Z
jetzt aber das gehört sich genau das ist
der Käse quasi dieser so also ich habe
jetzt so viel wie
geht okay okay bei drei 1
Z jetzt mal ohne Scheiß das ist gar
nicht so schlecht das ist das ist
interessant ist schon sehr speziell das
kann man ich bin ein Freund von süß
sauer und
so Chili in in in der Schokolade und so
war mal davon hatte ich noch nichts aber
Fisch ist schon wirklich
fortgeschrittene würde ich
sagen
aber okay das geht aber man muss sich
extrem lang gewöhen in der Musik würde
ich sagen es fehlen jetzt noch Höhen
genug B
ja we was meine von der Frequenz her das
wä noch ganz gut gewesen und ist das was
mit dem umwickeln ja mit dem umwickeln
ist super aber der aber ich finde
boah okay ich weiß was du meinst jetzt
schon ich weiß was du meinst also man
kann es essen man muss aber nicht man
muss über man muss nicht aber man kann
ihr könnt das aber zu Hause nachkochen
und uns eure Erfahrung
berichten auf jeden Fall sehr sehr gut
also
ze boah das ist schon
grwertig kommentiert drunter
erstens habt ihr noch mehr Ideen für
solche grauenhaften Rezepte also B ist
auch echt too much also noch mehr Ideen
für solche grauenhaften Rezepte für
unsere nächsten Gäste meinst du man kann
noch jemand hier einladen oder auf jeden
Fall also wie gesagt also der erste bis
war okay der letzte war auf jeden Fall
ja avangardismus würde ich sagen boah
ähm dann zweitens wenn ihr es wie sehe
ich sehe ich euch normal aus oder habe
ich ja so ein schokolad ne nee alles gut
und zweitens wenn ihr das nachgekocht
habt schreibt mal drunter oder dreht
selber Videos Videoantworten sind
gewünscht sagt wie es Euch schmeckt ja
ich bin extrem gespannt und vor allen D
Rezeptvorschläge Rezeptvorschläge
Rezeptvorschläge das werden man glaube
ich öfter mal
machen